you know I'd like to see in Denver DJ
versus Bradley Martin just throwing
things out there he's 260 he's 260
chatri he's 260 though yeah that's a
good idea Brendon I I didn't thought of
it but um yeah I mean DJ's you know kind
of in that zone where he's really really
cemented his status as the goat having
won World titles in in in uh both the
largest organizations you know UFC and
one in the world and then on top of it
um you know he's just I mean think about
it who in their right mind would do a a
super fight mixed rules against R Tang I
mean he went toe-to-toe with one of the
greatest Strikers on the planet um one
of the greatest knockout artists so you
know DJ's done it all you know I think
the only thing left for me for him would
be like a a super fight mixed rules with
Mikey mumii